I got to talk about some of the things I
see on your new season what do you call
it when those two people come running
out and they're playing like tennis with
their oh penis and Sir weiner Williams
we've got two male strippers to dress
like Venus and Serena Williams and play
tennis with their [__] and forget this
in front of Jaleel White Urkel and they
came out and they started playing tennis
with their [__] and Jaleel White had no
idea what was going on and he just saw
these guys with two massive [__] just
hitting and they were pretty good they
were volleying for a while you know why
I think it's funnier now I didn't
realize this I thought Jaleel White is
like a fan of the show and you call him
and he comes on the show no we TR we
dupe people into coming into that studio
we tell them the bare minimum we have a
lot of tricks some that I can't reveal
to get them into that studio and they
know nothing I mean if they if they
recognize me and they've seen the show I
can't help that but he knew nothing he
definitely didn't know he was going to
see two grown men play tennis with their
[__] was he pissed afterwards after she
was Serene so um
he was in shock he was in shock I
wouldn't say he was pissed I think he
was processing a tremendous amount of
stimulus information and emotion was
anybody ever really pissed oh yeah we
had people walk out we Lauren Conrad
from uh the hills she walked out I
vomited on the desk during the interview
then I slurped the vomit back up and she
didn't take kindly to that and then uh
T.I the rapper T.I walked out because
there was a lot of full frontal male
nudity as well that wouldn't go over
yeah the rappers from from the south
don't don't always want to see uh men's
penises yeah he was upset he was he was
not he was pissed he also like lurked
around the hallway afterwards like kind
of like menacingly like I was like and I
just be like hey thanks for coming on
the show like zipping in my dressing
room on the door
foreign